everybody how's it going
I flew in from France yesterday so I
just want you guys to know that the time
zones in my favor so I'm totally [__]
charged up right now I was super excited
to come here because I do as much public
speaking as I can possibly do and it's
always focus on different aspects of my
career or media or social media or
technology or filmmaking or what have
you but the reason why I was so excited
about Hustle Khan is because it's just
about the hustle and the hustle is my
favorite thing to talk about and I never
really get to indulge in it so I want to
sort of take you guys through a story of
like my life my career how it landed
where I am right now with a really
narrow focus on the hustle part which is
something I haven't I haven't really
really pulled apart yet so with that
indulge me all right
hustle where does it begin well I think
if I go all the way back I never really
understood the hustle until I found
something that was worth worth hustling
for and what I mean by that is I in high
school literally this was like this was
my goal when I was in high school and I
would say this like out loud and I tell
this my guidance counselors when I was
in high school my goal is to maintain a
straight D plus c-minus average which is
the bare minimum to graduate and when my
guidance counselor would ask me that
freshman year and I explained that as
frankly as I just explained it to you
and she's like that's terrible and I'd
be like well not really into it but I'm
here so just give me the diploma so I
can get past this because I didn't care
and I never did I never I never got that
c-minus d-plus diploma I just um ended
up dropping out when I was 4 to 15 years
old I dropped out of high school and I
say that not to
Laura Phi dropping out of school my kid
Owen is a sophomore in college this year
and he's a sophomore because he wants to
be and he's a sophomore 50 has to do but
for me it was a very different situation
like I had run away from home my
girlfriend was pregnant we were like
living in a trailer park had I had the
option to finish school I would have
sent her school but I didn't but then I
started working and work then was very
different from work now and work then
was was was tough and I I spent between
45 and 60 hours a week which is how much
time I spent working I spent 45 to 60
hours a week doing something I hated and
I think like that window of time which
is about three and a half four years of
my life was the most instrumental part
of my life it's a time my life that I
call like a phase of Arrested
Development and what that means is no
matter how much I grow no matter what
success I find or happiness I find or
struggles I have for the rest of my life
I will never get past being that kid and
that kid was like a 16 to 19 to 20 year
old I guess that informed like late teen
years and I worked in a restaurant
scrubbing dishes for a living and a
whole bunch of bosses and a bunch of
cooks in the restaurant they gave me a
hard time and then at home I had a baby
and I lived in a trailer park and barely
had enough money to make it by and no
matter what happens to me I like it just
got back from the South of France but
even so when I think like who am I like
what I ever I have these moments of
existential crisis that is what I
identify with and that's what I identify
with more than anything that's what
affected me the most and it was like
when I was a dishwasher when I scrubbed
pots for a living I was the best [__]
dishwasher that restaurant ever had
because that unlike high school that was
the first time I understood the more
hustle I poured into that job the more I
got back and I remember like an
assistant on the best dishwasher I'd
we could beat my system dishes were
always cleaned I'd sit down a silent
life like this whole sink clear being
like what that's all the dishes you got
for me because I knew the harder I work
like the more I get back and sure enough
like before I left that kitchen to move
to New York City become a filmmaker
before I left that kitchen I was a line
cook I had like two promotions pretty
big deal pretty I was making salads but
that's what that was where I understood
really the value of hustle and what
hustle meant and it was like the most
fair transaction ever you put a lot in
and you get more out and that very
rudimentary very fundamental
understanding was something that I first
tasted in the kitchen it's something
I've never ever ever let go up and to
get a little personal a little bit weird
right now cuz I feel like I know you
guys and pretty generous as you're
laughing at my weak jokes so far one of
my biggest frustrations in life when
Candis and I are with the marriage
counselor as I try to equate my work
ethic to my marriage or relationship
ethic and I'm like I just don't
understand I work so hard for this
marriage why isn't it yielding dividends
and both my wife and our marriage
therapist looks at us like something's
wrong with this guy so I moved to New
York City and I moved to New York City
at eight hundred bucks to my name no
high school diploma the only work
experience I had was in the back of a
kitchen and not even a great kitchen and
the hustle in New York City really sucks
it's super easy and fun to romanticize
especially now but the reality of those
days was absolutely miserable it was
like you know my apartment then I had a
futon in my bedroom and it was the
bedroom was so small I couldn't lay the
futon flat I just sleep on a futon that
was upright which isn't a big deal but I
also had a two year old at the time at a
shared bathroom in the hallway of my
building which is like particularly it
always checked you they always kept you
humble in the most literal way possible
when you have to
like take a leak in the middle of the
night you like put on your shoes and you
walk down the hall like it's a college
dorm room or summer camp but instead of
being sharing it with your camp mates or
your dorm mates you're sharing it with
like people who just got out of prison
and sort of like undocumented immigrant
it was a gnarly gnarly situation and in
the meantime I had a job that barely
barely barely paid me as a bike
messenger you know this is 2001 so you
paid for your cell phone by minutes I
don't know if anybody remembers those
horrible days or they couldn't take a
call till 8 o'clock when you're minutes
are unlimited but like I get all my bike
messenger assignments on my phone and I
remember at the end of the first month
as a bike messenger my bill was like
exactly $40 more than my income for the
intestines like cost me like ten dollars
a week to be a bike master as a pre
shitty job and and then like counting
out my first real job working for an
artist in New York City was an artist
who made sculptures name was Tom sacks
he made sculptures out of all kinds of
things one of the favorite materials
were those police line do not cross
barriers the wooden ones and a friend of
a friend told me he's like this cool
famous artist and he has a bounty of $10
per barricade I was like he had those
things are all over the city free money
so the next day I wheeled into his
office like 25 of them and he offered
he's like you want a job and I was like
yeah I want I was exactly what I want is
a job and I started working for him and
that was a pretty that was tough as well
it was it was a super super challenging
job well I was kind of a nobody I paid
ten bucks an hour to work in a warehouse
and cuts cardboard squares that have
slightly larger cardboard squares not a
super challenging job but a lot of work
but the hustle really began there I was
able to look around in New York City
this foreign place and all I saw were
people who are really doing everything
they could to chase down what it was
they wanted the magic of New York City
is that no one please know what I'm
exposed to lives in lower Manhattan
because they have to it's only people
who live there because they were
- and they pour that want into their
hustle because otherwise you just get
chased out of that it's so hard there
there's no relaxation there's no
comfortable life you can have in New
York City doing something you don't
really love you're chasing after it or
you're leaving it and it was after I
started working print that I was able to
feel that for the first time and the
hustle went a million different
directions I remember I was working for
him from 10:00 to 6:00 p.m. and then
after 6:00 p.m. I was like sneak around
his office filming stuff with my camera
with my big brother and then we could
edit little videos about our job and
then one day he kind of accidentally saw
those videos and he was like you made
these and again he was like yeah I
thought about to be fired he was like
this is all I want you doing from now on
is making these videos does it go okay
so cool sounds great really good at
making videos and that ultimately led to
one of his art collectors a very fancy
very very like distinguished looking guy
who like kind of person make eye contact
out and look like you don't want to see
you so you're scared and this guy saw
the videos needs okay will you make a
birthday video for my husband and I was
like birthday videos are my specialty
and funny you should ask because I was
looking at this guy and I'm like I don't
know a birthday videos mean to him but
whatever he wants I'm sure I can do it
well and this is like really the first
time that van and I my brother and I got
paid to do something with a camera I
mean working with the artists we're
getting 10 bucks an hour to make little
city silly videos we didn't really
understand what they could have been or
what they were but this is like a real
transaction he's like how much money and
I was like let me get back to you on
that and then we're like [__] that we
charge this guy and in any event when we
were like yeah it's like the birthday
video he's like here's a list of people
that want to have in the video wishing
Freddie my husband a happy birthday and
the first was like former President Bill
Clinton I was like okay it's gonna be a
birthday video just a quick digression
there were like 20 people of very
serious stature in that I mean like
heads of
companies his husband Fred Hochberg was
a huge politician was in the Clinton
administration was in the Obama
administration huge big deal of a guy I
didn't know that then I know that now
Fred he's a friend of mine but when we
went to interview the President Bill
Clinton I had a really funny joke that I
was excited about having the president
deliver and we went in there and it's
like I mean I look like a bum now you
should see what I look like back then
when I was at an actual bum and I just
remember Secret Service being like
talking to the handler being like yeah
we can't let these [__] guys in you
it was who are these people
and we finally get let in and we like
sit down in the conference room and the
woman comes in and she's like okay the
president will be right out this is
going to be 30 seconds and this is what
he's going to say and that's it nothing
I have this joke like that so we like we
waited and waited in like five minutes
ten minutes went by and left us alone in
that room and I'm looking at the
teleprompter set up and I'm like yeah
this is such a lame shot I start messing
with the teleprompter and I realize it's
just kind of like like like a Microsoft
Word like text document kind of thing so
just like ctrl alt and whole thing is
shut down and literally as that happened
in walks Secret Service like full-on
doors slam open stand back like this and
then in walks the president I'm like
whew and and he sits down and he's like
you know he's Bill Clinton he's like the
king of cool and he sits down he looks
into the top Ron for anything all right
I'm ready
and then the woman's like okay mr.
president right into the camera and the
teleprompter just a second mr. president
and I was like and I go over to the
president now the mr. president and as
I'm approaching him like like literally
like this The Secret Service is like aah
and I was like mr. president I have this
funny joke and he's like all right boys
I love that and I hear the court he
delivers the joke and then we stop
recording pack up the cameras and the
woman's like I almost got it mr.
president we got it we're out so the
video was like we played the birthday
video
it was very well received and then that
was kind of the beginning of bigger
things like because we showed that to a
roomful of people that were like you
know important we other people start
asking like who are these guys that make
that video how the hell they get Bill
Clinton to say that um and we were given
kind of other opportunities and that
very art collector was like I'd love to
do something with you guys and we're
like great we have this art series we'd
love to do and he gave us he gave us
hundreds of dollars to bankroll that art
project which was which was a series of
short videos that Ben and I wanted to
make and literally we use mr. wizards
world book of experiments to do at home
as our script and we shot them in the
bedroom of my of my apartment just up
against the wall and we called it
science experiments we did that couldn't
afford sets we couldn't afford a lot of
footage we couldn't afford anything but
we had these little interesting stories
that we shaped around science
experiments and then when that same art
collector saw that video he's like this
is going to stop traffic this is
incredible and we started pushing it
around we had an art collector in Miami
you showed it at Miami Art Basel while
there the the chief curator whose name I
literally remember
Jacobo Visconti he saw that he's a chief
curator of the South Paulo biennial the
biggest art show in Brazil the National
Art Show of Brazil he invited us to show
those movies science experiments at the
National Art Show of Brazil I was a 23
at the time I was like it was it was a
huge honor and all sudden my brother van
and I are sort of catapulted out as like
fine artists all of a sudden well funny
story on our way to the South Paulo by
Ennio we were stuck in traffic because
there's this gigantic traffic cam to get
to that art show I know it's a bit of a
reach but when the guy told us that our
movies to stop traffic in some some
version of that well we were stuck in
traffic trying to go see our movie so I
kinda kind of count and and also like we
got back to New York and it's it's like
this is where the hustle comes in it was
like well I'm this huge deal on the
youngest invited artist ever to go to
this
National Art Show in Brazil and it's
gigantic like I wore a suit I was
special and I get back to New York City
and it's like my rent is 1100 bucks a
month I still can't quite figure out how
to make that I still have a day job so I
can't and the realities of the hustle
that unromantic part that that is so
easy to gloss over when telling fun
stories of beings young artists and
getting to do these wonderful things
that was omnipresent
it never faded it never went away I
still struggled every week to come up
with 110 bucks which is how much around
trip train ticket cost at Connecticut
where my kid Owen was was going to
school and I would like stay in the
Attic of my dad's coffee shop there an
attic that was so unfinished I stapled
tablecloths to like the beams in there
to sort of make it feel like a room for
the kidney and we slept in the same bed
that those are the two sides of the very
same coin literally one week I'm in
South Paolo and like being celebrated on
this big deal and giving interviews and
doing all this and then the very next
week I'm asleep in the Attic of a coffee
shop with my with a baby and that's like
to me there was that that is the
struggle that is the hustle that is the
looking at that and saying well we're
the priorities here what do I want here
and and to talk more generally about the
idea of hustling it's like you know I'm
super old now I'm 36 some people laugh
at everybody else like damn damn but
there's a few isms or a few truths that
I've learned and it's like the beauty of
hustle the beauty of work is it will
truly like never let you down and they
only say the guaranteed recipe for
success is to dedicate your entire life
to something and you will say one of two
things will happen it's absolutely this
objective this is not an opinion you'll
either achieve that something or you
will have died trying
n either one of those they're kind of
the same thing I mean obviously one
slightly better than the other but
it's a guaranteed path to ensuring a
kind of focus on what you want and you
know one of my favorite movies is a
documentary about a rock band called
anvil and I've talked about this in the
vlog before and actually the band got in
touch with me after making out which is
pretty awesome but this story and I'm
digressing now but this story is a much
better example of what the hustle and
the commitment means then my own story
but in the movie they're like this rock
band that almost made it they Caravan
almost made it in the 80s but they never
actually made it and then they show them
now and these guys are living in Canada
the lead singer delivers trays of food
to grammar schools like a really for am
the 7 M kind of job barely makes enough
money to eat he's is 55 year old kind of
Haggard looking guy who who still every
weekend puts on like his leather like
chaps like rockers in the 80s and goes
and plays in a in a bar to like six
people five people the kind of thing
works like you cringe watching this
because you feel so bad for this guy and
you interview him and he's like he's
like I won't give up my dream he's like
I'm a rock star and I'm going to figure
this out and you watch it you're like
there is no way I'm planet Earth that
this guy is ever going to make it no one
will ever want to watch a haggard old
dead broke guy in his 50s who's all
wrinkles who's singing music that hasn't
been hit for 30 years no one will ever
there's no path to success for this guy
his family shuns and everybody shuts him
down but he will be refuses to give up
on this dream that's his dream refusing
and then what happens this movie comes
out [__] great movie like wins all
the awards and everything and because
this movie is so huge the demand to see
his band play goes through the roof and
all sudden he's now selling out shows
all around the world because of a movie
about how he wouldn't let go of his
dream like how you could never how
something like that could happen but it
is a testament to what never giving up
means so back to 2006 which is about
where I'm at you know I was given an
opportunity by an entrepreneur named Tom
Scott he
an entrepreneur who started a juice
company and sold out he started a TV
network and now he's running this whole
other things it's serial entrepreneur
he's one of the very few people in this
world that I would refer to in genuine
sincerity as a mentor of mine and I met
him and I was young and and he loved
with my brother van and I did and we did
some fun things for his little TV
network and he gave us a big opportunity
and he said let's do something big and
that's something big
ended up manifesting as the HBO show my
brother van and I did and that was the
experience of making that was amazing
but the experience of selling that to
HBO was an even more amazing experience
I was 28 at the time we sold it to HBO
for over two million dollars it was a
huge achievement there was like a thing
in Variety about HBO buying our show I
made it I had made it I was a big
[__] deal like my whole newspaper
wrote about it my teachers in high
school had to read about I hadn't made
it
don't applause that because this is this
is this is the story of what happens
when you let go of that hustle and they
bought the show in 2008 and for the
first time ever I kind of took a big
step back I was like okay well I've got
money now I've got success on everything
I need now and it was the first time
ever that I sort of leaned back and I
leaned back because I didn't have to I
didn't have to pay rent on my trailer
anymore like I was good and I just
chilled out and I have to say like those
couple of years were the most depressing
time in my entire life 2008 2010 make
anything they didn't do anything the HBO
show was caught up in all kinds of
bureaucracy it took two years about to
be put on the air and when that show was
on the air there was this moment this
very vivid visceral moment for me in
2010 and it was the same week that I was
in Los Angeles and all the movie that I
had produced a feature film that I
produce won Independent Spirit Award it
was like on stage on TV receiving this
award my parents thought at the same
time at an HBO show those premiering
every Friday night and HBO it was the
pinnacle of wide thought was success and
I was miserable
I was miserable because instead of
hustling instead of fly
instead of chasing down what it was that
I was into I was sort of basking in the
sunlight I was like taking a warm shower
and the water running over he was like
look what I did so I did it I'm good
and I was miserable I was miserable I
lost touch of what it was that I was so
passionate I lost touch of what the
hustle was about for me and that was
when I kind of stopped everything that
was when I went back to the drawing
board and that was when I decided to
start really focusing on YouTube YouTube
to me at the time was the most pure form
of hustle I was a guy like to share
ideas in perspective using moving images
using video and YouTube ensured it
wasn't about the politics of HBO and
that article in variety it was it was it
was certainly not about standing on a
stage and winning an award among
big-time celebrities it wasn't about
telling my parents and my teachers in
high school look what I did it was just
about me busting my ass for the Kraft
where nobody was watching nobody was
paying intended nobody was making me do
that only I chose to click upload and
that to me was was sort of the phase to
the 2.0 of my career was when I really
invested myself in YouTube and that led
me to all kinds of places three years
later and you know 150 million views on
YouTube later I'd carved out a career
for myself that wasn't the career built
my brother it wasn't a career from
YouTube it wasn't a career from a fear
rather it wasn't a career in feature
films it was something that was mine and
it was based purely on that hustle which
meant the world to me and around that
time 2013 is when I was invited to go to
MIT it was a fellowship that was a joint
program between the Rockefeller
Foundation that paid for it the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
Media Lab which put it on which
sponsored it and then the Sundance
Institute which sort of chose candidates
for it and they chose me and I remember
the time one thinking what going down IT
would mean for me as a high school
dropout
I needed that just so my dad would have
something else to talk about but it also
meant shutting down my company it also
meant dropping everything and moving to
Cambridge leaving a wife who was new
and pregnant and it was a gigantic risk
but this was sort of in success I think
the first major crossroads for me and it
forced me to reset it forced me to go
back felt like what is it that I want
what am I willing to do to chase down
what it is it excites me in life and I
did it and I dropped everything i sat
down my company and took big risk and
went back to school and I spent a
semester at MIT working out of the Media
Lab when I left there I left there with
this big fat new understanding which is
what happens in the world of technology
I'd only ever understood media it was
because of that that I was like [__] it
I'm starting a tech company I can do
this I've never written a line of code
in my life but I think I've got some
good ideas and I can find people who can
write code and that was beam and you
know beam for me was the greatest
departure this is the only thing I had
not even a semblance of a relationship
to what I've been doing and building my
entire career around it was purely about
technology it wasn't about media and
leaning into personalities and other
facets that I would say describe my
career in media and I think the more
interesting part about being the part
that I've talked about a lot less is
what happened a year and a half into
being you know we raised several million
dollars we had a big team we had a bunch
of success at the beginning because of
the way that I was able to leverage my
footprint in the social space and bring
a lot of people to this exciting idea
the idea that the product itself didn't
quite deliver on but a year and half in
we were just about out of money
we weren't growing at a rate were made
it easy for us to raise money and it was
sort of like what now what do you do now
and I made a decision then which my lead
investor did support although most
people on YouTube didn't really
understand which was like we had just
enough money to pay our bills and pay
payroll that beam and that now and
having to make a decision what do we do
now
and I came up with this great idea and I
was like why don't we take the entire
team on vacation and that was like that
kind of makes sense and I think it
totally makes sense so we didn't run
this big vacation we all literally went
to the Dominican Republic and I sat in
the Sun for a week
and that sounds crazy and stupid but
what came from that was this
understanding like the most valuable
thing we have is this team because we
work together so well we love each other
we make incredible products okay we got
this team what else do we have got this
great show that I call the vlog about
what we're doing here like there's a lot
here there's a lot here that's beyond
this one product that didn't make it
there's so much here and it was that
enthusiasm that was yielded from that
trip that sort of made me go back out
there and rethink what it was that we
had what the value prospect was on this
company and that ultimately manifested
into the sale to CNN and that's sort of
where I leave this talk and where I
leave us now which is that for the first
time in a really long time I'm standing
at the bottom of a mountain that's
probably bigger than any other mountain
I've ever looked at that trying to
figure out the [__] to do I mean it the
CNN just bought my company all of a
sudden we have tremendous resources we
have an unbelievable team we have all
the resources from Turner and above and
we have all these eyeballs looking at us
saying what are you going to do now and
when I look at it and try to figure out
how to build yet how to build a really
successful company and how to build it
under such scrutiny I don't entirely
know I don't entirely know how to do it
but I know what the number-one most
important ingredient is in making it
happen and that ingredient is the hustle
so that feels like it's like a really
full circle kind of witih in this talk
right here so I'm just going to stop
there but that's where I am now and I
think we're doing questions but I wanted
to thank you guys for coming and hanging
out hey Casey yeah I have like I'm gonna
kill you guys videos but they're on
YouTube and I'm so excited to talk to an
audience about the hospital I find it
that's cool all right they could always
use their phones you know we can always
use your phone yeah okay so we had a
handful of great questions from the
Facebook group I'm gonna go ahead and
pick one or two because we only have a
few minutes but Casey one question that
came up bunch is how do you manage to do
everything you're doing with a family
because you've had a child from very
early on
now you have a wife and a two two young
kids sure um you know people just ask
especially I was really struggling and
had a baby at home like how do you do
with a kid and my response has always
been I can do this because I have a kid
you know I as much of a crazy egomaniac
narcissist as I am it's like you need a
reason in life to do things and for me I
don't I don't know what else could drive
me if it wasn't for having somebody else
to do all this for and that's kind of
the role in my family plays
pragmatically how do I do it yeah so
another question I got uploaded a bunch
was how do you organize all your
projects which is quite similar though
to how you manage your time with your
family I mean the time management thing
is real it's hard I mean what a
literally manifest as it's like I leave
for work every day at 10:00 which is
after friends Tina's off on her day to
school and I'm home every day before 6
o'clock and she goes to bed at 8 and
then I'm working from 8 until midnight
and I work from 4 a.m. until 7 a.m. when
she wakes up so it's really just uh it's
a it's a prioritization and then also
you know I don't party I don't really
drink I don't I don't socialize I say
this in jest but I mean it like I don't
hang out with friends really know if I
have any friends so you're saying you do
all this for three hours of sleep well
my recipe for sleep is like I need three
to five to function but I can only do
that for like four or five days in a row
and they need like last night and like a
solid just eight hours of sleep and I'm
good but yeah sleep is a sleep too
[__] huge sleep in the wind or my two
biggest arch-nemesis in the squirrel
all right we have just a minute or two
left one question was that I think is
super interesting is what piece of
content that that have you created that
you're most proud of I mean that the
stuff that I'm most proud of is anything
involving the family because it becomes
a little portrait of my life that always
going to look back at and I think the
first year of making the blog before it
got so big it got really scary and I had
to stop putting my baby enix I was
scared of all kinds of realities but
when I look back at those early days of
the vlog and I see like what was my
versioning family then like that's
incredibly valuable to me any particular
videos of making search I mean yeah I
would say look at the one called a love
story it's about how Candace and I got
married like I watch that no matter how
much we're fighting I'm like I'd be like
her and last question what's been the
biggest failure so far for you sure the
biggest failure was um was celebrating
success was the biggest failure I think
the biggest takeaway from that is like
with each new success with each new with
every success should come a bigger more
ambitious goal and I think it took a
real couple years of without define us
this drive is failure to be able to
appreciate that anything left you want
to say I mean sure can you reset the
clock on to another 30 minute oh yeah
we've got about 10 seconds no I I just
want to thank you and you know we were
talking backstage before I came out I
just saying how infrequent it is to get
to speak to an audience that is as sort
of well informed as engaged as is as
focused as I've understood this audience
to be and I just say that like the thing
about the Hustle is that so few people
are actually willing to do it so if you
people are willing to put in what it
takes but every time you see somebody
drop off or take the safe route or do
something that is a huge compromise
because it's less risky that's just one
less person that you'll have to climb
over on your way to the top and never
forget that
thank you